and the giants right-hander kevin
gausman 6-2 197 pounder he's in his
eighth year at the big league level
gosman is 30 years of age
and this is what he has done in 29 stars
14-5 with a 2-6-5 era so two outs for
manny machado
that one lined to left darren ruff will
dive and catch it
how about darren ruff this is a roasted
nut heading out to left field he spears
it on a low backhander
and that's how this game gets started
another bullpen day today for the padres
pierce johnson gets the knot as the
opener and his second time doing so the
other time was on august 24th against
the dodgers he went one plus inning one
full inning and a walk and a home run
one and two and he strikes him out good
pitch goes to the breaking ball to get
him one down in the first inning for
darren ruff
did he go yes he did mark carlson rings
him up
what umpire said he offered some
back-to-back strikeouts for pierce
johnson air and a hit batter and all of
a sudden the giants have runners in
first and second with two down runners
go 3-2 to longoria swung on hit in the
air out towards left field playable for
tommy fan got underneath of it tommy
wearing the sunglasses makes the catch
and the side is retired padres have
runners at the corners and nobody out in
the second inning
he pops that one up crawford
will catch it that's big first out for
gaussman that'll bring up trent grisham
he's just filled with friars here in the
second inning
grisham hits a fly ball to left field
ruffy is gonna make the catch frazier is
tagging and he will tag up and score the
game's first run padres have a
one-nothing lead to sac fly for trent
christian puts the padres on top
mariznick with two on and two out
got him swinging with another 98 mile an
hour fastball the bill chris matt into
this game for the padres 38th game for
the right-hander the change-up
specialist he can eat up some innings
this is to left
and fan will
duck back to make the catch on crawford
first out of the inning wilmer flores
making his first start of the series
stands in he's at second base today for
the giants 1-1 pitch flores reaches for
it hits the change up in the air
straight away center grisham went back
now he comes in and makes the casual
one-handed catch
round it back to the mound chris matt
will run a bit he flips to first for the
out he and the giants though trail one
nothing and now it's the top of the
order
got him well
that's a good one right there and he
does it a 3-2 count one down in the
third for fernando oracle park 17 games
hitting it 277 six home runs at oracle
park
hit a ton to left down towards the
corner and it's gone home run for
fernando tatis juniors 39th of the year
and the padres make it two-nothing line
drive home run oh it's the change-up
grip and this one left up like any
off-speed pitch you leave it up it's
gonna flatten out it's middle in and he
says hello to the dog driving the car
two to nothing padres have the lead as
we move to the bottom of the third
inning
popped up
coming from everywhere and coming from
second is frazier to make the catch you
know the infield grass for out number
one
ground ball hits at third machado
on the run and in time for out number
two
fly ball out to
right field and it's pro far
who makes the catch
here comes trent grisham who knocked in
the first run of the game
that
strikes him out with the splitter
two down so chris matt the o2 pitch
struck him out swinging to sally tags
him out inning over he's running here
for the giants in the fourth inning
2-2 there it is to third machado to
second for one on to first for two evan
longoria grounds into the around the
horn tp two down two down for brandon
crawford
crawford hits it on the ground and into
left field right down that line
heading for two and he'll be
very out trying the swim move going into
second base but they gunned him down
trying to turn one into two and he is
thrown out to end the fourth inning two
on nobody out for the padres here in the
fifth gosman's 0-1 machado lines it to
center field bryant going back and he
will make the catch profile went about
halfway so he goes back and kind of
awkwardly went back to the bag
back to guzman
to crawford back to no
now he throws back behind profar at
third so they get the man in the middle
tati's at second base
padres ahead two nothing runners at
second and third two down fam lines one
into right field from third base comes
pro far adam frazier coming from second
he will score throw to second tommy
phams got a two-run double and the
padres take a four-nothing lead it's
four-nothing padres have the lead and
gets to the bottom of the fifth inning
on the ground with the backhanded third
for machado the long throw not a problem
manny machado down in third base handles
out number one
work it manny
it'll be
mike yostremski coming up
swinging a miss and yostrepski strikes
out
oh one topped him up lamont wade jr
on the left side of the infield frazier
tatis it'll be tatis fernando makes the
catch backpedaling on the infield dirt
on out brian
and here is brandon bell
driven to right field sending pro far
back
to make the catch on the warning track
tagging at second and moving to third is
bryant two down brian at third base and
brings up evan longoria
off the glove
and it stays right next to home play
unbeknownst to the catcher as bryant
comes in to score
daniel hudson with two men on and two
men out and wilmer flores coming up
fly ball center field grisham moving
over
we'll make the catch that ends the
inning now one on and here is wade
junior 2-2
wade to left-center field
fam chasing nobody's gonna get to it one
hop and up over the wall that's an
automatic double the stella with that
wild pitch will be allowed to score it's
four to two lamont way junior two down
for chris bryant
swing and a miss and hudson strikes him
out to end the inning trying to tack on
here in the eighth will myers pinch
hitting here with one out and runners at
first and third as myers lines this one
down the left field line fairball into
the corner coming from third is nola
grisham will stop at third it's an rbi
double for will myers and the padres
take a 5-2 lead manny machado with the
bases loaded
does go after the first pitch flips one
to shallow center and it's going to fall
in for a hit
one run is in here comes another the
padres tack on two more and take a 7-2
lead
so one down and here is longoria
mongoria to deep left field
this one is on its way and it is gone
into the bleachers home run evan
longoria maybe the giants aren't
finished yet his 13th of the year it's
to 7-3 so a two-hit day for ron gory a
double now home run so another base
runner and you get estrada the pinch
hitter coming up one two
curve in the dirt and kicks away from
nola that's going to allow wade to score
ruff goes to second it's 7-4 but the
main thing for estrada is keep the
pressure going
strata pops it up
shallow center
incoming is grisham to make the catch
for out number two the giants are down
to their last out here comes brandon
bell
kyle tipped into the catcher's mitt for
strike three and it ends the ball game
so the padres holding on and they win
this one seven to four the final